I don't know why I'm nervous this is
fine it's just heat the Chili's are
really hot like all over my mouth
[Music]
I'm Beryl I produce a series called
around the world where I take one topic
and I look at its iterations around the
world this week I am looking at spice
when I think about spicy food I
immediately think about China and it's
amazing spicy cuisine which we did a
story on so the Mayo salad of a higher
salame it's awesome but you what do you
larger or I think about the u.s. the
people choking through ghost pepper
challenges because here sitting spicy
food can sometimes be more of a
competitive sport than an enjoyable
experience but in other parts of the
world spice is flavor it's just as
important as say sweet or salty so I
spoke to seven people in seven countries
to see the different ways spice gets
eaten around the world
this is the spice episode
in making this episode I decided two
things one I am NOT looking for spicy
soup relatives so no spiciest on the
planet you can't make it through this
dish attitude and two and looking at
cuisines where spice is a part of the
culinary identity so let's begin before
we start I'm gonna say this
I do like spice but I'm also kind of a
wimp so what am I gonna do I am going to
be testing out different methods that
claim to help ease the burn of spice as
we go country to country I'm not gonna
do milk or ice cream though I feel like
they have been done I'm trying things
that are a little bit more off the
beaten path okay here we go when you're
cooking with cajun spices there is a lot
of recaii and Pepin in Jamaica we use
Koch bonnet peppers that's a very key
ingredient ya hungry she will take what
you gotta work and go you might need it
on her way all this horrible could be my
a Contessa minute a Catholic guy right
here I cat uncle prick we're doing most
people would put in little bit chilly or
even a large red chilly it definitely
makes food a lot better in terms of
tastes in Malaysia
[Music]
being an Indian spice does make every
single food better the right amount of
spices actually bring in joy in your
taste buds dried red peppers are
commonly used in Korean cooking
they're called go giugiaro and the paste
form which you see a lot is called
gochujang so the first method that I'm
going to try is sugar the Scoville scale
measures the spiciness of a chili pepper
and the guy who invented it figured out
how much sugar is needed to offset the
spice of the pepper the spicier the
pepper the more sugar you need so I have
a spicy Korean stew and I have just
plain sugar definitely got spice to it
sugar lard
yeah it works I can feel the spice on my
lip still but if you're in a bind the
sugar the sugar works I'm gonna eat this
little fella gotta be I'm anna-marie
sugar mama myung-kil Nidoran de comida
named chairman who has kimeta jujube no
Chewbacca Queen and guava Tyrell Hamish
is also pretty rude or Kingdom assertive
and Giannini that wasn't my intention
oh joy toaster oven improvement a
cultural home a lot a lot I'm a loser
car door opens a sriracha car wheel
Google search on a hotel room and a
hoochie Anita Waddell hi Laurine in your
factory
Amita hungry yet Thank You jato integral
Breanna saw tongue Romans in your Amita
Lohan will get you gyro in pooja pooja
Quattro ultra senator hoylman a new
massive an adenosine de OCHA Quatro
Quatro Vicente concept Eminem Chiquito
Michaela wen Zhong yang di Bao Yamazaki
Vanessa Keaton 800 Santa Clara Daniel
Nevada
normal name Emma junkie territory and
moment soon he had a doctor on film
muscle to be dominant
of the stresses we talking we can dance
along Indian cuisine is known for its
use of red chilies and the Gunter red
chili which is commonly used in this
Brioni dish is very famous another
really common way to help with spice is
to have dairy so yogurt is the next test
that I'm doing I have chicken Brioni
from India and a green chile to go on
the side so you'll take a bite of the
food have a bite of the chili Chile's
good
whoo there it is oh my god okay honestly
it's helping but the sugar helps more oh
man we're good spice is not pain at all
it is good when you use it in the right
amount
my name is Raja Montana I live in
Hyderabad the southern part of India
spices are very important in our culture
and 100 percent of all our dishes have
spice in it today we are cooking
Hyderabadi dum biryani the spice from
Hyderabadi biryani is from the red
chilli we use it is from Guntur and
couturiers the red chilli hub for the
world the word biryani comes from a
Persian word called Berrien which means
fried before cooking so we make our own
red chilli green chilli and ginger
garlic paste fresh right before the
biryani is being cooked it is very very
important to cook it in layers because
every single layer has its own amount of
taste
you smell a lot of different spices you
can't stick to one the flavour keeps
changing
to someone who has never tried Hyderabad
eat chicken dum biryani it is actually
very difficult to explain but it is more
of having firecrackers in your mouth
it changes your mood it uplifts your
mood spice does make every single food
better but the right amount of spice is
always needed cayenne peppers are a big
part of Cajun cuisine and while they are
spicy they're not that spicy so I have a
Cajun gumbo which I've had to add a lot
of Louisiana Hot Sauce to because I need
to test out
chocolate chocolate is high in fat
although I know milk chocolate is higher
in fat I only had dark chocolate in my
house and it's supposed to help with
spices mmm so gumbo is great I was heavy
on the hot sauce the flavour of chalk
was really strong but I don't know it's
not helping all that much this is one of
the weaker contenders spice makes food
delicious but it's how will you use it
you can over spy something or you can
under something you got to know it just
amount of right my name is Brett a ver I
live in Houston Texas jambalaya is
native to South Louisiana it's something
that was a true Cajun dish when you have
festivals when you have family
gatherings when you have birthdays even
at funerals food is a big thing
[Music]
jambalaya is a dish that can feed many
people you can have a pot that'll feed
300 people and it's still very easy to
cook a true authentic Cajun food it's
all about flavor spice enhances it but
it's not spiced as the main ingredient
like in this jambalaya we're gonna cook
today you're gonna taste a shrimp and
you're gonna taste the crowd and your
taste andouille sausage it still has the
flavor of the Kanye
but it's something you don't want to
touch your eyes and once you gather on
your fingers because it will burn you up
spice is something that you use at a
very good level and you got a nod a true
Cajun cook will know how to adjust a
spice Thai cuisine is known her being
spicy it utilizes a lot of Thai chilies
which are these very tiny chillies and a
good rule of thumb
the smaller the chili the spicier so I
have a coconut Thai curry YUM
and I'm gonna be trying peanut butter
peanut butter is super high in fat and
fat is supposed to help break down the
spice oils you feel the spice in the in
in the back of your throat okay
[Music]
that was exhausting okay it works it's
like a very all-encompassing flavor
though so I've now completely lost the
flavor of the coconut curry my mouth
tastes like peanut butter but I did a
good job at coated my entire throat and
mouth so I'm not tasting any more
[Music]
pump it made me from some hung up on
Hainan on when high minutes a hat-trick
died so they have killed her Harwood
Kingdom he dies on mokuba
doesn't look like and don't let me
finish up Cobra hang me from Christian
[ __ ] and kid not good job when a lot of
mayhem came to Abraham pin hand hybrid
up compact I have to me soon a cop will
do it happen hit me packed me mama hampi
aluminum cans ideas i don't fire coming
from came home imply Mikasa pet you lay
out like a turtle competent repeat I
have built a home contain shop your
child from Montana compete Nam real
public North a cop had me miniprep in a
bottle container chop chop chop la
putana petrulio me once on my night in a
capital ha my Mia haunted bond toccata
me when I'm pickin team you want Oh yep
this one we saw spicy
tennis this one is a can i buy some
Malaysian food uses a type of chili
called a bird chili which is around 13
times hotter than a jalapeno very spicy
so I'm gonna be testing out alcohol for
this one
alcohol is supposed to help but it needs
to be a high proof so I'm using vodka
and I have absolute citron so this is
going to be interesting oh my god okay
well this one worked pretty well I mean
vodka is pretty powerful so huh although
now my mouth tastes like vodka
[Music]
to me spice is good I love spicy food
spices make your cooking of a lot better
my name is Aubrey I live in Petaling
Jaya Malaysia there is very very spicy
chili which is cultivated in in Sawa
this is super hot and spicy chili those
who can take spicy food would find this
chili bit too much to handle
so laksa obviously represents Malaysia
in the map of the world in a sense that
it is one of the few traditional or well
known food from Malaysia it is almost
similar to curry the ingredients that we
use in strong laksa basically shallots
lemongrass galangal to have a little bit
of spiciness in it most people will put
in little bird chili first taste that
probably receive will be the taste of
spiciness and the combination of herbs
and spices it's going to taste a little
bit sour spicy sour it tastes flavorful
spicy and unique to Malaysia
[Music]
so scotch bonnet peppers are super
common chili in Caribbean cooking and
fun fact they're named after the shape
of a Scottish man's hat anyway I have
jerk chicken from Jamaica here and I'm
going to be testing out acid aka a lime
as a way to help with the heat hmm good
I'm definitely getting the heat in the
back of the tongue that worked really
well strong contender for first place
I think spice makes food better
it gives it life it gives it some
spontaneity
it gives it something something that
will make you say yes I'm glad I'm alive
my name is presenting Blackwood I am
from Kingston Jamaica and I will be
preparing authentic Jamaican jerk
chicken for you guys today you have to
have your flavor with scotch bonnet you
have four different colors you have the
yellow the red the green and you also
have a purple one purple one is the most
spiciest one and it looks very pretty
and it looks so amazing but it's the
hottest one and it will really scourge
of your tastebuds
it recipe the combination of the African
and attained a heritage that was
originally here and it's just matured
over the years to become what it is
today a jerk chicken is a small chicken
times 100 so you get all the flavors of
the Caribbean coming all the scotch
bonnet the pimento the garlic onion and
then you'll have the hits of vinegar
then had a touch of sweetness coming in
that's what jerk chicken tastes like it
doesn't give you that burning sensation
it's a gradual build oh so when you're
eating it it's mild it will give you a
lot heat but flavor it's very robust and
then once you start to eat it and it
gets to the middle of your tongue and
then it starts to sweat you know once
you start to sweat you start to feel
very heated
and it's like home okay up I've eaten a
scotch bonnet pepper
[Music]
I'm a little nervous for the last dish
it was just called fish with chilies it
uses scotch bonnet peppers it's a West
African dish I'm gonna be testing it
with honey just like sugar but a
different consistency
it smells hot I don't know why I'm
nervous this is fine it's just heat
it's just heat my mouth is really
burning
honestly the flavors are so good the
spice is powerful
that's enough chilies that's enough
that'll do maybe it's cause either
spicier you need more sugar I feel like
the sugar granules were more effective
than the honey sure my penmanship JC a
Contessa tom hollie la nuit ma the pima
usually an empty sample wanna oh yeah Oh
silly Pima its IANA Pacheco merci c'est
fait le mabuki
Jiao silly Poisson auntie auntie zhou na
boku prima delicata el chupanibre paso
de la copa de la la chief element of a
camper de tomate de prema voiceover de
sel de los de Pedra da yo Jamie Dalek
elephant in family face messier the
barbecue sit Le Poisson supplements a on
peppermint ISA come maybe could be
mimosa Alice the little static it is
blue put the P Marquis you deserve a
camera Oh Lana Theresa
let's occupy do let's get people going
my takeaway from this project is that
first off I have a new appreciation for
spicy food
I've always liked it but I don't know I
feel a little different I think I
appreciate it more spice is a flavor for
sure and it's not something that should
be conquered it's something that should
be appreciated makes your food taste
better it makes people happy if it
doesn't make you that happy though I can
tell you this
[Music]
vodka got rid of the burn fastest I mean
it makes your whole mouth tastes like
vodka but it doesn't taste like spice
Pawar weapon at camp I can hand pick in
CSUN Conahan my Catholic open at erotic
and report on spice is needed I mean
sometimes when you're eating your food
you want to be awakened with life and
you want to be energized over all spices
life we like our food to be spicy we
enjoy our food to be spicy which is why
India is called the spice hub of the
world there is no life without spice
food is the ingredient that brings all
of us together Kajal dear aunty of
Mahajan expansion and how far you do a
combination and Kohaku you or even she
gave me also Macedon in the Michigan
Ammiano mash it's me aware know a
chapter on top of it 11 Daniel nakahara
old asset ownership the question I think
I was raised you know with all the youth
spicy cooking's in my family spice of
course it gives you a little bit of a
pain sensation it's the kind of feeling
that some can take some
[ __ ] and all of them man
Sasha facility Omer it pretty much look
what see any people as well ha in
Concord
Cynthia suppose and foods true Cajun
food is about flavor
I know it's known around the world where
it's real spicy with Tanya and this and
that way I drank a lot of iced tea to
eat it but in the South and true Cajun
you want to be able to enjoy it once you
eat it you know say whoo man that was
good
[Music]
you
[Music]